ouais
manille la capitale des philippines dans
l'enfer des embouteillages matinaux la
mégapole de 10 millions d'habitants
s'éveille déjà asphyxiées par les gaz
d'échappement en pleine ville la
décharge de vitas à cause des fumées et
des vapeurs toxiques
les philippins l'appel smoky mountains
la montagne fumantes le matin sur cette
gigantesque poubelle à ciel ouvert c'est
l'heure de pointe
dans les ordures jusqu'aux chevilles
ils sont des centaines de chiffonniers à
guetter le déchargement des camions
beaucoup d'entre eux sont des enfants un
ballet invraisemblable où chacun se
précipite pour avoir les meilleurs
morceaux
seuls ces deux prêtres français le père
thomas et l'abbé mathieu se préoccupe
des gens qui vivent sur la décharge de
vitas on a mis des gens à la poubelle
leur vie 24 heures sur 24 c'est la
décharge des poubelles enfer sur terre
enfer sur terre qu'est ce que vous
pouvez imaginer pire vous êtes dans
votre maison
quel est l'endroit le pire vous pourriez
vous cacher qu'est ce que vous pouvez
imaginer
[Musique]
né à versailles il y à 31 ans l'abbé
mathieu est arrivé aux philippines en
1998 pour y faire sa coopération
il y a rejoint le père thomas 49 ans ce
jésuite corrézien venait alors de monter
ici une association humanitaire
la fondation un pont pour les enfants
lorsqu'ils ont découvert les conditions
de vie des chiffonniers de manille les
deux prêtres ont décidé de leur venir en
aide
d'autant plus que tout le monde ici leur
tourner le dos à cause de l'odeur qu'ils
s'imprègnent
y compris sur leur peau les chiffonniers
sont les pauvres qui sont les plus
marginalisées parmi les pauvres parce
que même s'ils vont de l'autre côté de
la rue dans des bidonvilles où il n'ya
pas de chiffonniers les gens ne les
apprécie pas à cause de leurs mauvaises
odeurs sur la décharge les deux prêtres
connaissent tout le monde ou presque
derrière le chaos apparent
ils ont découvert une véritable société
avec ses codes et sa hiérarchie il ya
des chiffonniers rama chez les métaux
les plus précieux notre qui ont le droit
de ramasser la ferraille d'autres qui
ont droit de ramasser le plastique
donc chacun à sa spécialisation en
fonction de l'ancienneté de l'autorité
que peut avoir le chiffonnier sur les
autres c'est la loi du plus fort une
jungle dans laquelle les plus audacieux
sont les premiers servis
à l'arrivée des camions poubelles les
accidents ne sont pas rares
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas très bien il ya des bactéries
au centimètre carré mais le père thomas
nous emmène au bord de la décharge
c'est là que des grossistes rachète les
sacs de détritus au poids canettes
boîtes de conserve ou vulgaire déchet
plastique tout est recyclé exploiter
un peu plus loin le père thomas tient à
nous montrer la spécialité locale
on la trouve dans ces petits restaurants
que fréquentent les chiffonniers au bord
de la montagne de poubelles des morceaux
de poulets récupérer dans les emballages
des fast food de mani re et ramassé
directement sur le tas d'ordures les
bouillantes de nouveau et ensuite il
il le free pensant ainsi éliminer un
certain nombre de bactéries
évidemment c'est pas le chaos
je ne lui conseillerais pas d'en manger
une portion coûte 20 pesos 30 centimes
d'euro
c'est plus du quart d'une journée de
salaire sur la décharge
dans cet enfer les plus vulnérables sont
bien sûr les enfants
le plus âgé n'a pas dix ans inconscients
du danger ils creusent toute la journée
à quelques centimètres du bulldozer le
petit enfant en rouge la convoi près de
la pelleteuse et si vous faites
attention il a même pas de bottes il est
pieds nus comme sur cette décharge là on
trouve même parfois des déchets
hospitaliers
ça peut faire des catastrophes c'est en
propre et rappeler n'importe quelle
maladie et ça fait des catastrophes
on a un enfant kg et qui est décédé
l'année dernière parce qu'il a été
enfoui en fait ils montaient sur les
ordures comme ça et en fait ça s'est
écroulé donc il a été enfoui sous les
acculer les
autre danger le ballet des pelleteuses
et des camions poubelles
jesse boy a perdu deux doigts en montant
sur une benne à ordures j'ai grimpé sur
le côté du camion et quand la plateforme
arrière s'est levé ma main s'est fait
coincer et là j'ai réalisé que ma main
était écrasée puis j'ai crié maman maman
on m'a ensuite mis dans le camion
et c'est alors que j'ai perdu
connaissance
et vous
[Musique]
tout au fond de la décharge la couche
d'ordures atteint plusieurs mètres
d'épaisseur
mais les tris successifs n'ont pas
laissé grand chose à ramasser et
pourtant ici il y a encore des enfants
qui fouillent le sol reynaldo à 8 ans il
passe dix heures par jour à creuser à la
recherche de petits morceaux de métal
depuis deux ans l'abbé mathieu tente de
le faire sortir d'ici
quel âge avait tu la première fois que
tu es arrivé ici six ans tu as combien
de frères et soeurs
douze dont deux sont décédées et où sont
tes parents ils sont à la maison
ma soeur mary jane est avec eux elle va
à l'école
et toi tu ne vas pas à l'école pourquoi
ça nous n'avons pas d'argent pour payer
l'école tu es fatigué tu as mal au dos à
la fin de la journée
reynaldo va vendre sa collecte au
ferrailleur qui attend au board de la
décharge pour deux gros sacs en tout 15
kilos de métal il encaisse 68 pesos à
peine plus d'un euro
le ferrailleur revendra le métal deux
fois plus cher
[Musique]
combien tu gagnes et 60 les sauces je
lui dois encore de la monnaie garde les
deux pesos et on va tuer maintenant je
vais voir ma maman un simple fossé
creusé dans le tas d'ordures sépare la
décharge de l'endroit où vit reynaldo un
bidonville constitué d'abris de fortune
planter directement sur les couches de
détritus les gens s'installent un peu
n'importe où il plante or baraquements
et ça ça grandit en fait le village
s'étend quand on est arrivé ici vous
aviez pas de maison ici et pas de maison
devant la haie puis progressivement en
fait les gens s'installent ils n'ont pas
de plafond bien ce n'est quelques pas de
kim est d'envoyer bien c'est les trois
planches de bois et puis des déchets
plastiques et métaux les pires ça fait
la maison mes enfants mais la maman mais
à grand mère ici ils sont peut-être
trois ou quatre mille difficile de le
dire avec précision des familles
entières qui s'entassent dans quelques
mètres carrés point c'est entre la
montagne fumantes et la baie de manille
les enfants jouent et se lave avec
insouciance dans une ossature et de
pollution à la fin de la journée
reynaldo rapporte à sa famille le peu
d'argent qu'il a gagnés sur la décharge
[Musique]
assez d'argent aujourd'hui je ne sais
pas votre avis c'est déjà pas mal 60
passionnant ah oui c'est très bien très
bien
reynaldo et sa famille vivent là dans
une seule pièce d'à peine 12 mètres
carrés
prenez 12 à dormir là dedans 12
une table quelques meubles et pas de
matelas
la famille de reynaldo a été poussé ici
par l'exode rural
pour quelles raisons êtes vous venu ici
à tenter notre chance est votre avis la
vie meilleure ici ou en province ce qui
est bien ici c'est que c'est plus facile
de gagner sa vie par contre l'argent 120
rapidement que pensez vous du fait que
vos enfants ramassent les ordures
inquiète
bien sûr il peut leur arriver un
accident je m'inquiète parce que le
risque est très élevé j'aimerais mieux
qu'ils fassent autre chose pour gagner
de l'argent mais il n'y a pas d'autre
choix et notre avis dépens de cela pour
venir en aide aux habitants de la
montagne fumantes
le père thomas et l'abbé mathieu ont
créé un centre en plein coeur du
bidonville une fois par jour et comme la
plupart des petits chiffonniers
reynaldo vient y manger une assiette de
riz et de poisson et toi tu as soif
depuis l'instauration de ce repas
gratuit la malnutrition a quasiment
disparu chez les enfants de la décharge
pour l'hygiène il y encore des progrès à
faire
qu'est ce que vous leur apprenez je leur
apprend à se laver les mains
c'est important de se laver les mains
avant de manger quand ils ont très faim
ils ont tendance à tout de suite passer
à table alors il faut le leur rappeler
on a commencé par ce petit centre en
fait qui a été monté pour la nutrition
et puis pour essayer de faire de la
préscolarisation pour les enfants et
puis ensuite on a grandi avec ce plus
grand centre ici vous avez des enfants
de tous les âges
vous avez des enfants qui sont là pour
une préscolarisation pour les préparer à
l'école et puis des enfants qui sont là
en soutien scolaire ou des enfants qui
sont là pour avoir des activités
scolaires parce qu'ils n'ont pas de toit
l'école le travail de reynaldo sur la
décharge ne lui laisse que peu de temps
pour profiter du centre dans ses moments
libres le petits chiffonniers rêve d'une
autre vie plus tard je voudrais être
chauffeur de bus
pourquoi
[Musique]
parce que ma mère veut que je devienne
chauffeur reynaldo d'après toi quand tu
seras grand
tu préfèrerais rester ici ou aller vivre
ailleurs
ici ils n'imaginaient pas d'ailleurs une
image inc ici mais il n'a pas d'autres
références il peut pas imaginer un
ailleurs la seule chose qu'ils voient
qui change des poubelles
c'est un monde irréel qui est le manque
de la télévision mais cesser ses doutes
ses de l'intouchable connaissent quand
même battu auxerre
on se sent terriblement impuissant
devant ça on se sent terriblement
impuissant évidemment m'apporte des
repas on permet à des enfants de pouvoir
être être scolarisés à pouvoir
évidemment vous permet tout ça on permet
à de faire un suivi médical de certains
enfants tatin c'est merveilleux c'est
merveilleux il faut continuer pourquoi
problèmes que ça se multiplient mais
mais en temps se sent impuissant on se
sent impuissant parce que vous avez
sourire des enfants là mais la réalité
pour eux la majeure partie de la journée
elle reste là elle reste là elle recèle
à fouiller les poubelles à fouiller les
poubelles qu'on éprouve à certains
moments des doutes et des moments de
découragement oui mais on doit vraiment
essayé de dépasser ces moments là sinon
on s'enferme dans le désespoir
c'est facile non c'est pas facile vous
avez désolé des moments d'attenté cours
oui j'en ai encore et
et j'en aurais encore mai
c'est l'espérance qui doit être la plus
forte
malgré tout
mais pour les deux religieux il y à
encore plus grave plus urgent que les
enfants de la décharge car cela au moins
ont un toit une famille
il existe en revanche à manille d'autres
enfants qui eux ont perdu toute attache
ce sont les gosses des rues qui hantent
les trottoirs orphelins ou fuyant les
coûts et les abus sexuels au sein même
de leur famille ils seraient plus de
10000 rien que dans la capitale
philippine
pour les prêtres de la fondation ces
enfants sont la priorité absolue c'est
pour eux qu'ils ont créée il y a huit
ans un premier centre d'accueil
[Musique]
ici une trentaine d'enfants réapprend à
vivre
ils ont entre 3 et 18 ans tous ont été
ramassés dans la rue il ya seulement
quelques jours ou quelques semaines ils
se sont laissé convaincre de venir là
pour tenter de changer de vie pour la
plupart ils n'en sont pas à leur premier
séjour parmi les enfants qui sont ici je
vous en avais qui ont fait de multiples
allers retours dans la rue d'autres qui
sont déjà un peu plus stable est en tout
cas ce que l'on peut dire c'est que tous
ont vécu des choses terribles en étant
dans la rue ils sont obligés de survivre
par de petits boulots par par le vol
mais aussi hélas bien souvent par usage
de la prostitution
assistés par des éducateurs philippins
le père thomas et l'abbé mathieu tente
de réhabituer les enfants à une vie
réglée
la principale difficulté ici c'est
d'éviter les fugues et la redescente
dans l'enfer de la rue un travail
difficile
toute la journée les deux religieux
écoute sans relâche les angoisses et les
doutes des enfants du centre essayez de
demander quand vous voyez un enfant dans
la rue essayé de le faire venir dans un
centre en lui disant tu auras un nouveau
t-shirt ou rituels où tu dormiras
beaucoup plus calmement et au rap et le
bruit de la rue viennent rapport 1 100
fiches par contre faites lui comprendre
que dans un centre on fera attention à
lui n'aura d'importance pour quelqu un
va et vient et c'est ce qu'il fait
rester calé le dk quel est le défi quand
un enfant vient de la rue c'est lui
faire comprendre qu'il a de l'importance
pour nous il rentre pas comme un numéro
parmi les autres enfants non pas du tout
faut qu'il ait de l'importance faut
qu'il sorte comme un enfant dans une
famille doit trouver sa place
chaque jour la fondation envoie des
équipes d'éducateurs arpenté les rues de
manille à la rencontre des enfants
aujourd'hui mac mac et ferb doivent
rencontrer une petite banque du quartier
de l'automne au centre ville la plupart
ont déjà fréquenté le centre
ces enfants vivent dans la rue bien
qu'ils aient des familles et une maison
ils n'ont pas beaucoup de contact avec
leurs familles et ils se droguent en
sniffant du solvant c'est leur seule
activité pendant la journée dans la rue
ils sont une quinzaine d'enfants à avoir
élu domicile sur un terre-plein coincé
entre deux voies rapides
voici là là là là comment vas tu ils ont
entre 12 et 19 ans il n'est pas encore
midi mais la plupart d'entre eux sont
déjà sous l'influencé du rugby un
solvant industriel inhalé à même la
bouteille ou dans un sac plastique
le solvant leur donne un sentiment de
puissance et le pouvoir de faire
l'impossible ça leur donne l'illusion
qu'ils ont des pouvoirs
ils peuvent faire bouger le soleil la
lune les étoiles
parfois ils se prennent pour superman ou
leurs personnages de dessins animés
préférés
j'imagine aussi la nourriture qu'ils ont
envie de manger ils sont capables
d'imaginer cela dans leur sac
les éducateurs ont toujours quelques
jeux et des crayons de couleurs des
activités simples qui ne sont en fait
qu'un prétexte qui veut jouer avec moi
moi c'est quel jeu les dominos ouais moi
je sais que de minorer toi
notre but de gagner leur confiance une
fois qu'on a gagné cette confiance alors
il est temps pour nous d'intervenir et
de réaliser l'intention qu'on a prévu
pour eux parce qu'il est très difficile
d'intervenir auprès d'un enfant s'il ne
nous fait pas confiance de notre race
préparée psychologiquement les enfants à
quitter la rue c'est un travail de
longue haleine
bon on s'en va on revient samedi
prochain il faudra plusieurs rencontres
comme celle ci pour parvenir à
convaincre un seul enfant du groupe
d'accompagner les éducateurs au centre
d'accueil mac mac connaît bien ce que
vivent les enfants qu'il rencontre il y
a 20 ans il était chiffonniers et il a
lui-même passé cinq ans dans la rue
ces choses qu'ils ressentent maintenant
je les ai prouvé aussi heureusement je
m'en suis sorti et je voudrais arriver à
leur faire sentir que eux aussi peuvent
changer leur vie d'une façon ou d'une
autre je me sens tellement triste parce
qu'ils ne comprennent pas ce qu'ils font
ils sont victimes des circonstances
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui ne
veulent pas voir leur situation
c'est lorsque la nuit tombe que les
prêtres les éducateurs de la fondation
partent en tournée de ramassage
le soir les rues de manille fourmis de
gamins livrés à eux mêmes au cours de
ces opérations baptisées big night
les enfants qui ont été préparé pendant
la journée seront ramenés au centre
d'accueil
ce soir l'abbé mathieu et ses éducateurs
commencent leur tournée par divise oria
le plus grand marché de manille qui
fonctionne jour et demi avec ces
quantités de nourriture à portée de main
c'est le refuge privilégié de beaucoup
d'enfants des rues
[Musique]
et ils sont des dizaines à dormir à même
le sol à l'abri des arcades
[Musique]
la bretagne
si l'on devait le prendre c'est celui ci
l'a rasé la ville est complètement
shooté tous au rugby alors qu'il savait
que venir il fallait qu'il ait pas sa
fin est assez bon il a mis un peu de
seulement 60 truc là et c'est ça qui
renifle et du coup il est condamné
joseph bonjour comment vas tu mettrais
bien et vous avez manqué mon père j'ai
envie de venir avec vous d'abord mac mac
dans le petit groupe il ya beaucoup de
filles la plus vieille a tout juste 12
ans ce sont évidemment les plus
vulnérables à ton avis la vie dans la
rue est elle plus difficile pour les
filles que pour les garçons c'est plus
difficile pour les filles
pourquoi parce qu'il ya toujours le
risque de se faire violer il ya des
hommes qui peuvent nous emmener dans des
endroits louche
voilà c'est le danger qu'en est il des
filles qui font des choses pas bien pour
gagner de l'argent des filles qui font
des choses pas bien
oui voilà pour gagner de l'argent il y
en a mais il y en a
même des jeunes vous aussi de temps en
temps oui une vie est promise à la
prostitution à la puce est certain donc
même s'il ya beaucoup plus de gars sont
dans la rue en fête sur ya 80 à 90% des
enfants des rues ce sont des garçons
mais la situation des filles c'est une
situation d'urgence extrême mais à
manille il y à des situations encore
plus urgente que celle des enfants du
marché
l'étape suivante de l'équipe de la
fondation est certainement l'endroit le
plus sinistre de la capitale le
cimetière de saint guen dan dans un
quartier populaire non loin de la
décharge de la montagne fumantes
combien sont ils à avoir trouvé refuge
parmi les tombes pour échapper aux
dangers de la rue partout des dizaines
d'enfants surgissent talla proche de
l'équipe
certains vivent là depuis des années et
tous sont shootés au rugby le solvant
qui fait des ravages
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà ils sont une trentaine la
trentaine d'ong et partis légaux ils se
réunissent parce que joe réussi à avoir
une télévision en général il ya un petit
paiement chacun paye un peso pouvoir
regarder la télévision tous ensemble
quoi voilà sont des jeunes
le jeune qu'avec concept de rugby tu es
juste devant ici la séparation de la
fondation qui malheureusement est parti
et il s'est mis avec une heure une jeune
fille ella deux enfants et 105 en sa
compagnie au tennis et marvin jennifer
est pas populaire c'est la première fois
que je me suis que je suis venu ici
je savais plus quoi penser parce que
quand on sort de cet endroit là et
on a l'impression qu'on va dire qu'on a
rêvé et non qu'on a cauchemardé et on
n'a pas un vrai succès réel vous avez
des enfants qui vit dans des tombes
voilà les enfants qu'on choisit comme en
droit de vivre parmi les morts et
d'oublier la vie oubliez les vivants
nous ont quittés la vie et choisissent
des habitudes de mort et c'est ce qui se
passe ici d'améliorer son taux sur les
tombes sur tous les tons ils choisissent
le second a choisi sa drogue c'est
difficile vous voyez quand on a un
groupe comme ça il ya une espèce de
mouvements de groupes caisse pour que
les enfants quittent cet endroit cet
enfer eh ben c'est pas facile de faire
désirer le paradis un enfant qu
attendent sur une pierre tombale les
éducateurs thiel une consultation
médicale improvisé dans leur trousse de
secours
de quoi soigner coupure galles et
infections l'assistance psychologique en
prime qui montre des toutes petites des
petites blessures en général l'équipe
des siècles par trois sont déjà guéris a
rien fait mais vous savez nommait de la
bétadine et de matam peu d'alcool ça
permet d'engager la discussion et ses
beaux stades entiers ont besoin et c'est
ça qui demande qui recherchait pas son
clip attention à rincer puis koné
regarder ce qu'on espère soigner a
notamment permis c'est une petite
coupure qui n'a fait à peu près 1 mm et
demi et depuis pas mal face à rechercher
qu'on fasse attention à lui c'est tout
ce dont ils ont besoin
après plusieurs heures passées dans les
allées du cimetière l'abbé mathieu et
son équipe repartent heureux
deux enfants ont accepté de les
accompagner retour au centre l'abbé
mathieu ne se fait pas d'illusions neuf
fois sur dix les enfants qu'ils
recueillent retourne dans la rue pour
ces deux là la partie n'est pas gagnée
c'est une première victoire c'est une
preuve lecteurs parce qu'ils ont quitté
la rue c'est déjà un pas énorme
la deuxième victoire c'est si ils sont
encore là demain matin produits victor
ces six mois à la fin de l'année demain
fête des papas après parfaite
chaque enfant
la première étant sûrement qu'ils aient
quitté la rue ils ont quitté leur groupe
et c'est déjà énorme
c'est un premier pas deuxième part on la
table demain et on verra bien